oh yeah so I don't remember exactly
where I was I was on my computer so he
could have been anywhere but it was just
a post on any cool news that was just so
you know tell us you know share your
stories about comic about you know for
you know for the new Morgan Spurlock
movie oh no I never do you know I didn't
thinking about I was sitting I was a
birthing come and gone when you're
dancing over it up you know it was like
oh I tell them that I'm ready to do that
really i'll stay hard maybe I will
that's back in the hand where I guess
other day I got back to it later like
follow useful vote absolutely get some
better go ahead cuz I'll see faces a big
things to me oh yeah like I'm not just
that we really know about each other
hacks on the con that's what we started
dating and also we both work we're
trying to actually anything i worked on
illness website that we were actually
the first thing i did was i didn't
really have been a free entertainment
for originally trade paperback that
that's out now we had to do a we had to
do a longish hair days on Fortune's you
know so we kind of talked about our
history would come i'm also sorry man
young hugs we stopped filming when she
went to operate my fellow humans compost
straddle half of detailing Michael and
set out for a few years set it off the
story line on there
I'm actually write even no idea but no
where is everyone William Wilson we both
kind like went to film the world's
luxury but we'll definitely be a good
icebreaker a plane when i whenever we be
except one and that song is really gross
this grand science fiction backdrop
after yes that's one of the things my
wife and I are joined on you so just
like meaning kind of like minded cool
that's interesting at first time I feel
this is the first time I've been back to
United States yeah that's kind of the
environment going right up to people who
have your interest you lack so let's go
it over there let's go make a zombie
movie yeah
you